now uh
moving on to the u.n as we reported just
a few moments ago uh the u.n general
assembly voted on that resolution
demanding that russia withdraw its
troops from ukraine and as you heard 141
voted in favor five against russia and
belarus uh among those five ahead of
that vote russia faced urgent calls to
end its assault on ukraine but
moscow still denies that it's targeting
civilians
they have come to the ukrainian soil
not only to kill some of us not only to
shift our course and priorities
they have come to deprive ukraine of the
very right to exist
they have come to resolve the ukrainian
issue
as their propagandists claimed
just stop and think
whether these wars remind you of
something
today we call on russia
to stop its unprovoked
unjustified
unconscionable war
we call on russia
to respect the sovereignty
and territorial integrity
of ukraine
we call on another neighbor of ukraine
belarus who you've just heard from
to stop supporting
the war and stop allowing its territory
to be used to facilitate this aggression
we are not carrying out strikes on
civilian facilities or civilians
don't believe in the large number of
fake news being spread around the
internet on this
peaceful scenarios of ukraine could
happen
if the radicals are concerned about
preserving civilian lives in their
country
rather than hiding behind them there is
no reference to this call on the
resolution for us to vote on
russia's advance on the capital kiev
appears to have stalled for the moment
that's according to u.s officials it's
believed that 80 of russia's combat
power that was assembled along the
border is now in the country president
putin mobilized 190 000 troops according
to estimates ukraine has 209 000 active
duty soldiers and last week president
zielinski activated thousands more
reservists to support them joining us
now from washington dc uh lauren
esperanza who's director of the
transatlantic defense and security
program at the center for european
policy analysis good to have you with us
uh lauren do you agree with that
assessment that russia's advance on the
capital has stalled or is are we are we
seeing as a change in
tactics by russian military going on
here right now
well thanks for having me so i think we
saw
originally a russian military that was
not well organized uh that did not have
sufficient logistics and support they
they suffered some early failures
running out of fuel and food and we're
still seeing some of some of those
failures on the ground and so i think
that is why we're hearing these reports
of maybe that convoy being stalled and
those those failures are real but what
we're starting to see is russia also
shifting its military tactics because of
those failures and it's resorting to
more of its traditional way of war which
basically involves applying massive
firepower to major civilian population
centers and we are seeing uh the use of
artillery and rockets and missiles uh on
on major cities like kharkiv and and we
saw the tv uh tower being struck down in
kiev yesterday
and i think you know despite the the
russian claims that they are not
striking civilian targets i mean we have
evidence in reporting that directly
contradicts that i mean we have seen
everything from a university to a
maternity clinic to our apartment
buildings being bombed and the reality
is that this this conflict is this war
is getting bloodier and brutal uh
more brutal by the second and and i
think unfortunately that's a sign of
what's more to come and this is really
turning into a humanitarian disaster so
what is russia's end game though what is
it they're trying to do militarily here
sure so a lot of what we're seeing is
that they're trying to advance towards
kiev i think this is a big center of the
of the war that they are trying to
surround and encircle the city
and and and siege the city to to topple
the government and hopefully
they hope to install a puppet government
a pro-russian government and i think
that uh their strategy uh what what i
would expect to see next you know they
are approaching kiev uh i think would be
we'll start to see some more cyber
attacks they'll try to cut off
lines of communication they'll try to
cut off roads so that the city cannot
have access to be resupplied they'll try
to undermine the ukrainian military's
capacity to talk to each other to have
command and control and then you know
when they encircle the city they'll try
to to squeeze and and what we could see
is a very destructive urban warfare
scenario where you kind of see this
house to house fight but
i think part of the why we're seeing
this extreme bombardment now with the
russian strategy is to essentially rough
up the city as much as they can before
they kind of actually advance into the
city and send troops in into cubes
i would also just try it
to say that ukrainian forces have
mounted a spirited defense has has
russia
bitten off more than it can chew
well i think this is one of russia's
massive miscalculations about this has
been the resilience and the spirit and
and the fighting power of the ukrainian
people of the ukrainian forces the
ukrainian society
and they certainly have the the will to
pay the ultimate price to defend freedom
and democracy and their way of life the
values that we in the west have taken
for granted and uh so i think that that
has a lot a huge role to play in all of
this the will to fight it we've seen
that the morale on on the russian side
is very low we see a lot of abandoned
equipment and kit on the streets of
ukraine which indicates that the
russians are not
dedicated they're not
really in this fight and that really has
a military impact in all of this
so
the other thing i i would say is that
even if you know they end up uh taking
cube
the political end game here is is a
mystery to me because i i don't see how
russia would ever be able to install a
puppet government that would stay the
staying power of anyone that they would
install is very short-term because
clearly the ukrainian people are never
going to
allow that to to stay and they will
fight tooth and nail and
they're clearly not giving up on their
freedom uh and and so i think the
russians have a still a significant
fight ahead of them
good to talk to you lauren many thanks
indeed lauren
lawrence browns are there
live with us from washington dc
thank you